hi YouTube my name is Tamara chambers
and this is terras ever singing last
week I watched drug drudge Jen Judge
Dredd with Sylvester Stallone and today
I am watching judge or no just regular
regular Dredd you didn't see my video
last week I said that I thought that
there were a lot of really cool concepts
that just didn't get fully realized in
Judge Dredd so what I'm hoping that they
do or at least is cool and entertaining
said give me those Dredd prediction
tweets y'all hashtag camera's never seen
with a Karl Urban Dredd gif gif gif
alright y'all very excited to watch this
film let's do it where the first one was
fun because it was genuinely a bad film
this one is fun because it's it's a fun
film it's a pretty decent action flick
right up front it already had way more
of a comic book feel dread all of the
judges their motorcycle and and their
suits looked way more practical and
cooler and less gold which you all want
to know the very best part of this film
three guesses I'll give you three
there's no Rob Schneider
I'm sorry make you stop Karl Urban is
also a better Dredd I have a weird soft
spot for Sylvester Stallone seeing a tag
I've not seen him in very much I just
like want to like him as an actor as I
really loved him in rocky but I say that
like that's like this profound thing
that no one else has thought he was such
an odd dread to me and I know in in
Judge Dredd they chose to make him play
as like this fake not fake but like this
programmed human versus like someone
with emotion this one they didn't go
that route I'm sure it's implied in his
just because that's what he's in the
comics but they didn't like make it a
big thing in this one and I think that
was smart
it allowed this dread to still have that
top exterior still he never took his
helmet off which I thought was really
cool and still be dread but it didn't
feel as like beep beep boop I am NOT
emotion sentence oh shit I'll show also
the guns beginning the hotshot gun where
he shoots the guy in the mouth and then
like he completely what does he do
implode from the inside amazing a devil
boner needs one you keep his name off of
your dirty lips I wrote oh my god
there's no Rob Schneider and there's an
awesome psychic rookie judge there's a
ton of drug-induced slightly a tiny bit
cheesy slow motion slow mo and in this
film and and it gets to be kind of a lot
like it it's an interesting content
which is like a little cheesy and
execution it works because it's because
of a drug oh mama is the leader of this
giant gang and the people who are
putting out slow low the drug are is
that gang mama
gang mama Kamala clan I think they're
called right up top they're talking
about mama and they're like gasps she's
feminized a man with her teeth ha I've
never heard that term before but honest
honestly being honest here love it kind
of love it she yes go ahead
go right ahead my liege so Anderson and
Dredd go in for a day of work to see if
she's ready and they go and they take
out these druggies missile drug den they
find one of the gang members of Mama's
clan and she doesn't like that so she
closes down this entire housing
community adorably named peaches tree or
peach trees it's like so cute right and
then she's like hey everyone just kill
the judges
it feels very like per G like
impossible situation these two people
trapped in this place can't get out
thousands of people coming to kill them
nothing so they're going through this
adorably named concrete death castle and
all I can think is I just hope that they
don't fall in love I hope that Dredd and
Anderson don't fall in love doesn't need
it she's this cool badass psychic he's
just cool badass judge they can just be
cool badasses on their own it definitely
doesn't need it
original Judge Dredd just definitely
doesn't need it one thing I thought was
weird though is they hug around the gang
member that they had arrested earlier
they're bugging him around in this like
eighty story housing community complex
because they can't let him go they don't
know for sure if they can kill him or
not and it's just a weird extra burden
for them to have and I understand what
was written in because they needed that
weird extra burden but nonetheless a
weird extra burden I really enjoyed that
they didn't right dredge be like a
tattletale police officer like like they
did with Stallone he was really like two
above the law
this Dredd was still Dredd like he still
was very like I am the law very like law
abiding citizen but he let some things
go like later on he he doesn't kill
these two children who were trying to
kill him which that's bad his death he
should have he should have killed them
but he doesn't in the original almost
alone he when he finds Rob Schneider and
Rob Lee I was just trying to save myself
and like he just got it was too much too
much Dredd just you know Andy Tim starts
off with the mind of the gang member for
some answers and it is not he's like
this is my mind can I do whatever and
she's like yeah anything he starts doing
like sexual acts with her and she's like
no no and then like shows him and all
the bad things he's done
you go girl but then later he has her
like at gunpoint and it's like why just
do that again go into his brain again
mama who bore me
do not like it mama
okay then it is a real that there are
dirty judges and he wrote ocean dirty
judges come in and charge mama 1 million
credit to take out dread ocean they tell
mama to kill Anderson ocean so they go
to kill Anderson with her own gun and
then it kills him the gang member who
they've been lugging around this whole
time thank goodness goodbye goodbye and
dread gets shot by one of the dirty cops
he's out of bullets and the dirty cop
has him at gunpoint and dres like wait
and the dirty cop gives this incredible
speech so the great judge dredd says
wait did you have you scared for dizzy
when we're talking about as weak
pathetic like or do you think something
magical can have a twenty we for justice
Oakland like she shoots him up obviously
it was definitely predictable but
doesn't really wonderful speech to that
actor tape then dread passenger as a
full-on judge when she thought that he
was gonna fail her cuz she lost her gun
that's an automatic fail she just had
weld that terms
Tamra chambers she's a path overall it
kept my attention both movies I thought
were really entertaining but for
completely different reasons I really
loved what the story went with this new
one like I said there was some cheesy
moments definitely in the execution of
the slow motion effect but I didn't like
make mad look some speed sex in the
first one you'll find it a better movie
but less fun to watch I do think that's
the case I was kind of scared to say it
because everyone is like ah this one so
much better you're gonna hate the first
I don't blast and busting the first one
you'll make Carl Urban's angry turtle
face when you're mad for at least a week
it's a preacher talking out
oh this is the first time I've caught
this call-out and I'm so excited and
also can't think of anything always the
way you made it you might get tired of
the slobo alone the hipster llama says
you must be dreading this one I I stop
you're being you're ruining this the
female sidekick is way better than any
comic relief
wink wink cough probs cough Snider cops
camera servicing she was way better than
Rob Schneider ever even was close to I
think I mean she was more comparative to
Diane Lane so I was like Anderson Diane
Lane character where I think in my mind
the comparable ones and I really liked
both of them that she just had such a
larger role also not like love interest
territory which i think is cool and she
was a psychic and it was super neat and
kind of got Judge Dredd out of his like
this is all that we can do with the law
blah blah blah these are the stables
rules rules she was like nah man I'll
just going to his head
damn him and then did it it was awesome
like I said I really enjoyed this as an
action flick and I think I enjoyed the
last one as a goofy cheesy kind of
guilty pleasure flick thank you so much
for watching and for the predictions as
always I tweet about it like once a week
check out for that next week I'm pretty
sure I'm doing demolition man which I'm
very excited about bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you